[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue ravi de vous retrouver
par sa clé TV c'est toute l'actualité de
votre territoire aujourd'hui je vous
propose de découvrir le Graduate School
c'est un concept encore peu connu en
France ces écoles rassemblent des
formations de masters et de doctorat
elles sont adossées à de prestigieux
laboratoires de recherche l'Université
de Paris Saclay en compte 17 et un
institut des sciences de la lumière je
vous emmène ensuite à la ferme de
trubuil alors c'est une histoire de
famille ce couple d'agriculteurs s'est
tourné vers le maraîchage et la vente
directe ils font partie du réseau manger
local un site internet que vous
connaissez certainement enfin nous
reviendrons sur la première édition des
échappées vertes et les balades
biodiversité une façon de découvrir ou
redécouvrir les espaces naturels de
votre territoire nous vous en avions
parlé le mois dernier c'était dans notre
agenda agenda à retrouver à la fin de
cette émission
on commence donc cette émission avec les
graduettes school je vous le disais le
concept est nouveau il est peu connu en
France l'Université de Paris Saclay en
compte 17 dans 3 grands secteurs
sciences et ingénierie sciences de la
vie et santé enfin science humaine et
sociales alors le principe est simple
c'est de créer des synergies entre
formation et recherche les étudiants de
masters les doctorants peuvent donc
aller travailler dans des laboratoires
de recherche pointus des laboratoires de
recherche prestigieux écoutez les
explications de Benoît Gabriel il est
professeur et directeur de la Graduate
School biosphera
une graduée school c'est un concept un
petit peu nouveau dans le monde
académique en France en fait il s'agit
de faire travailler ensemble des équipes
de recherche et des équipes pédagogiques
qui assurent des formations au niveau
gradué c'est-à-dire après la licence
donc en gros on s'occupe de parcours de
Master puis de doctorat donc on va
jusqu'à bac + 8 dans la graduée school
dont je m'occupe donc la mission
principale des graduations en fait c'est
de faire de lien entre la formation et
la recherche donc les nombreuses équipes
de recherche qui sont présentes ici sur
le plateau de Saclay et pas seulement et
puis donc les équipes qui assurent les
formations donc au niveau Master et puis
pour les doctorats en fait ce sont les
mêmes équipes qui font à la fois la
recherche et l'encadrement des
doctorants donc le principe des gradués
school c'est d'associer tous ces équipes
et de réfléchir ensemble à des nouveaux
parcours de formation des projets de
recherche en fait coopérer puisqu'en
fait dans la graduel school biosphera
donc je m'occupe nous avons 7 grands
partenaires cette institution donc trois
organismes de recherche dont l'île Ré on
trouve aussi le CEA et le CNRS on a
trois universités donc Université Paris
Saclay et les universités qui sont dites
associées à Paris Saclay donc Evry et
puis Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et puis
donc on a l'école ingénieur un gros
ParisTech à laquelle j'appartiens
ce qui est intéressant dans les
graduations en fait c'est que c'est la
première fois que sur le plateau de
Saclay les acteurs de la recherche et de
la formation travaillent vraiment
ensemble de façon concertée à travers
cette structure qui est commune en fait
pour les étudiants un des avantages
c'est d'avoir accès à des laboratoires
de recherche qui sont connus en France
et dans le monde qui font une excellente
recherche dans les domaines de la
gradueschool et pour les équipes de
recherche inversement ils seront plus
impliqués en fait dans les formations et
donc pourront encadrer les doctorants
des stagiaires et profiter en fait de
cette synergie entre la formation et la
recherche
dans la graduelschool biosphera en fait
on s'intéresse à la biosphère donc le
vivant on s'intéresse à la biosphère
dans son environnement qui est aussi
social politique économique donc
relation entre société humaine et
biosphère et bien sûr c'est
particulièrement important quand on
pense aux grands défis sociétaux que
nous devons relever que ça soit les
changements climatiques la sécurité
alimentaire la santé globale incluant
celle des écosystèmes la préservation de
la biodiversité ou le passage à une
économie qui serait basée non pas sur
des ressources fossiles mais les
ressources biologiques donc on retrouve
finalement la biosphère au centre de
toutes ces transformations et c'est ça
qui fait l'originalité et la richesse en
fait du projet porté par biosphera
[Musique]
vous qui vivez sur le plateau de Paris
Saclay vous devez connaître le site
internet manger local la ferme trubly
fait partie du réseau ce couple
d'agriculteurs propose des fruits et des
légumes de saison qu'ils vendent
directement dans leur ferme leurs
clients sont conquis regardez
[Musique]
bienvenue sur exploitation à Saclay donc
on est agriculteur depuis plusieurs
générations sur le plateau de Saclay
donc on a connu les différentes
évolutions de liés à tous les enjeux de
la région et du territoire de Saclay
on a cherché un projet de
diversification par rapport aux grandes
cultures qui étaient produites sur
l'exploitation donc on produisait
essentiellement des céréales
et du colza sur l'exploitation et on a
cherché à
développer d'autres choses et on s'est
tourné assez rapidement vers le
maraîchage et la vente directe pour
valoriser notre espace agricole
aujourd'hui on a 25 hectares de fruits
et légumes cultivés donc à la fois une
partie sous serre une partie la plus
importante qui est en légumes de plein
champ et aussi une partie de verger
d'arbres fruitiers donc pomme poire
principalement
c'est principalement une clientèle
locale qui qui consomment nos produits
donc qui habite dans les communes du
Plateau de sacré ou limitrophes
quelques-uns viennent d'un peu plus loin
mais la grande majorité vraiment vient
du territoire également une petite
partie de la production est vendue sous
forme de panier dans les entreprises et
une autre partie sous forme de commande
groupée auprès des étudiants qui sont
tous arrivés sur le plateau de Saclay
comme on est parti de de zéro en 2010
quand on a commencé le projet il a fallu
déployer toute l'exploitation pour
qu'elle arrive à la taille actuelle et
finalement ça on a fait que accompagner
la demande des consommateurs et ça
marche principalement par du
bouche-à-oreille puisque on a juste
quelques informations des fois qu'on
diffuse sur les réseaux sociaux ou par
le biais de notre page internet de la
ferme mais
principalement c'est du bouche à oreille
des gens qui passent devant qui par
hasard qui connaissaient pas qui
s'arrêtent alors on se dit peut-être
qu'on répondait à une attente des
clients enfin en tout cas nous on fait
quelque chose qui nous plaît aussi et
c'est surtout ça je pense qu'on a réussi
à trouver une diversification qui nous
plaît et on a réussi à proposer à
quelque chose qui plaît aux clients donc
c'est voilà donnant dedans
on parlait de plus en plus notamment par
rapport aux problématiques énergétiques
et de résilience des territoires le fait
de manger local ça fait déjà vivre un
agriculteur à côté de chez soi ça fait
vivre une économie agricole parce que on
a aussi toute une équipe autour de nous
qui
[Musique]
les légumes sont exceptionnels sont très
frais ils sont très beaux ils sont
cueillis de la veille ou de jours avant
et puis ça change forcément du
supermarché il y a une ambiance aussi on
se connaît tous on échange des recettes
avec des produits frais etc
on suit les saisons et puis les aléas
aussi du métier d'agriculteur la météo
qui est favorable ou pas favorable enfin
voilà on a des bonnes et des mauvaises
surprises avec la nature quoi
[Musique]
et maintenant des échappés vertes cette
première édition a été une réussite vous
étiez plus de 400 à participer à cette
découverte de la zone de protection
agricole et forestière du territoire du
plateau de Paris Saclay 4115 hectares
préservés alors cette journée a été
riche et beaucoup d'animations le
rendez-vous avait été donné ici un
escape game de 10 km à séduit beaucoup
de visiteurs nous allons revivre donc
cette première édition avec 6000 par an
elle est chef de projet agriculture à
l'EPA Paris Saclay
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est la première édition de
l'événement échappé verte donc qui est
une journée pour découvrir la zone de
protection naturelle agricole et
forestière du plateau de Saclay donc
cette zone c'est 4115 hectares qui ont
été préservés de l'urbanisation donc ils
sont constitués 2500 hectares d'espaces
agricoles et puis
1640 hectares d'espaces naturels et
forestiers et donc aujourd'hui ce qu'on
a fait c'est que on a emmené donc les
habitants donc beaucoup de familles et
puis quelques étudiants du plateau donc
on avait 450 personnes inscrites donc on
les a emmenés sur un parcours de 10 km
un escape game au cœur de la zone de
protection pour découvrir cet espace qui
est vraiment à proximité de ces nouveaux
quartiers et puis donc là l'après-midi
c'est plutôt un village
festif avec des animations autour de
l'agriculture de la transition
écologique pour voilà prendre du temps
et puis découvrir les produits locaux et
puis tout ce qui se passe sur cette zone
de protection
nous l'équipe d'organisation on est
vraiment content de l'ambiance très
joyeuse très très festive et puis on a
vraiment des retours très positifs des
personnes qui ont fait l'Escape Game qui
qui ont pu faire beaucoup de
d'animations sur le parcours des jeux et
puis découvrir un peu mieux les
différents milieux naturels les types
d'exploitation agricoles entre des
exploitations plutôt céréales des
exploitations très diversifiées avec du
maraîchage et puis voilà passer par ces
lieux qui sont qui sont assez
remarquables dans le patrimoine du
plateau de Saclay
[Musique]
dans les prochaines perspectives sur la
zone de protection naturelle agricole et
forestière on a le lancement la révision
du coût du programme d'action qui est en
fait un programme qui regroupe tous les
acteurs une trentaine d'acteurs en fait
pour valoriser et préserver ses espaces
donc on termine le premier programme
d'action et là cette journée c'était
aussi pour marquer le lancement de de
toute la concertation qui va avoir lieu
pendant la prochaine année pour définir
avec tous les acteurs du territoire les
nouveaux enjeux ce qu'on veut ce qu'on
voit pour valoriser cet espace et puis
du coup voter un nouveau programme
d'action à la fin de l'année 2023
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces espaces préservés sont aussi des
espaces de respiration des coins de
nature ou la faune et la flore peuvent
respirer dans ces nouveaux quartiers qui
émergent sur le territoire alors il y a
des panneaux pédagogiques qui sont
installés et qui donne de précieuses
informations et le pape et sa clé vous
propose des balades biodiversité nous
avons rencontré Gwenaëlle Le Quéré elle
est écologue et directrice du projet
Confluence
[Musique]
on se retrouve sur le quartier l'école
pretty technique ou bien de s'achever
une balade de une balade biodiversité
organisée par le paie à Paris
Saint-Clair qui propose aux habitants et
aux gens aux usagers du quartier de
découvrir les espaces qui ont été mis en
place et qui peuvent accueillir à la
fois une faune diversifiée de la flore
tous ces espaces de respiration du
quartier
qui sont aménagés au nord de quartier de
l'École polytechnique
je crois qu'il y a pas mal d'intérêt sur
ces espaces on a beaucoup de retours qui
sont qui sont très positives au coup de
curiosité et c'est pour ça d'où la
demande de ce réseau de panneaux
pédagogiques qui ont été disposés là ces
derniers mois et qui permet d'expliquer
un petit peu et la philosophie de la
création de ces espaces et puis leurs
usages la façon dont ils sont gérés etc
c'est des sujets qui qui intéressent
beaucoup ces nouveaux acteurs du des
quartiers
les balades de biodiversité là c'est la
deuxième année que ça a lieu il y avait
une première visite qui a eu lieu une
année dernière où il y a deux ans qui
avait eu qui avait eu pas mal de succès
en sortie de pandémie et là on a
l'impression qu'il y a vraiment une
appétence pour pour la découverte de ces
espaces dans le dans le quartier
peut-être plus largement là on est sur
le quartier de l'École polytechnique
mais ça aurait pu être aussi sur le
plateau dans d'autres dans d'autres
secteurs et je crois que l'idée c'est de
c'est de renouveler cette cette
proposition de découverte collective
d'années en année donc soit dans la
semaine de la biodiversité comme cette
année ou dans un cadre dans un autre
cadre à définir
[Musique]
pour être au courant de ces balades de
ces échappées vertes il ne faut pas
rater notre agenda le voici vous n'avez
toujours pas vu Paris sa clé paysage et
bien courez à la Maison de
l'Architecture cette exposition
itinérante si installe du 28 novembre
2022 au 9 janvier 2023 et le premier
décembre une conférence epaille Saclay
réunira le paysagiste Michel des vignes
le plasticien Bernard Monino un
rendez-vous animé par l'historien de
l'art et commissaire de cette exposition
Marc Partouche c'est à 19h
connaissez-vous les ordinateurs
quantiques les crampons qui mesurent les
performances sportives ou encore
l'hélice de bateau silencieuses ces
innovations n'auront plus de secret pour
vous après à avoir vu le showroom
technologique de Paris-Saclay le
rendez-vous c'est le 10 novembre sont
présentés des jeunes entreprises et des
technologies à la pointe de l'innovation
enfin ce ski club vous propose une offre
unique d'incubation et d'accélération
vous avez jusqu'au 25 novembre pour
intégrer cette incubateur vous pourrez
ainsi bénéficier d'un accompagnement
personnalisé individuel et collectif
voilà c'est la fin de cette agenda c'est
déjà la fin de cette émission on se
retrouve très vite pour un nouveau
numéro de Paris Saclay TV et d'ici là
restez informés sur le site ea
paris.fr à très vite
[Musique]